yeah Cinderella - dreams come true and
if you think that title is unbelievably
boring in generic well you just summed
up this entire sequel why do people
think there needs to be more than
happily ever after that's a perfectly
good ending it's the most popular ending
of all time but know this thrilling
fairy tale needs to continue with the
fairy godmother now living in the palace
for some reason I guess she wasn't happy
just living as a pile of sparkling dust
however that works but instead she likes
to read to her mice friends but oh no
they won't do something nice for
cinderelly this is the major concern of
the film so she recommends that they
make a book with all the fascinating
stories that happen in the castle that's
right all three of them because that's
all that's we're telling in an hour and
a half and honestly I don't even know of
those are really worth telling yep it's
another one of those anthology stories
where they just throw three separate
stories together don't really connect
them that well and well everybody
suffers for it the first story is about
Cinderella learning how to be a princess
she has to learn how to dance ride and
dress write and turn away commoners and
cook boring food it's hard but it's okay
some R&B pop songs help her out
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo so this is love all
these classic songs hell with that
that nobody will ever remember now we
have pop songs sung by pop singers whose
nobody's names they remember even if
they sneeze it by accident you want a
real good laugh fast-forward to the
credits and hear their R&B version of
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo I'm not even kidding
it's pretty hilarious but that's just
one of the three boring air stories jack
is apparently tired of being a mouse so
the fairy godmother turns him into a
human but being a human is really hard
and you can guess where as goes
from there
the last story is about a stepsister
Anastasia wanting to get a date for the
ball the fact that any of them would go
to the ball after everything that's
happened is kind of funny but what's
even funnier that Cinderella is totally
okay with helping her out yeah all
that's sabotaging like you're in a room
over givin Cinderella just wants her to
discover how to be her true self
but being her juice
hope is harder the sequel in so many
ways reminds me of Bell's magical
journey right down to all the stories
that they tried to tell and don't really
tie in together is it quite as bad as
that one I guess not I mean the
animation is 10 times better than
deserves to be and give it some credit
they tried to tie it together even if it
was really loosely and they kept the
stories really short just down to three
but big shock you know these stories are
really interesting and definitely not
worthy of the title Cinderella - at
least buting the beesting call it Beauty
and the Beast 3 this is marketed as a
direct sequel and it's obviously not
it's just some stories they threw
together but come on haven't you ever
want to hear Cinderella say this hair
ooh is hair ill and haven't you ever
wanted to see Lucifer wear Rastafarian
hat oh my god what now it's so stupid
the only thing that's kind of likeable
in this whole thing again aside from the
animation is surprisingly Anastasia is
kind of a likable character I know I
made fun of the fact that Cinderella
helps her out and yet technically in the
story it doesn't really make sense but
the way they animate her and the way the
voice acting is done I do genuinely kind
of feel sorry for her it's the one thing
I didn't really expect and I guess it's
actually done kind of okay oh no I feel
they did a surprising if not sporadic
job of suddenly making her kind of
likable but what does it matter they
still put her in the same
stories with the same misunderstandings
that suddenly make everybody turn away
and go oh no he doesn't love me all that
this movie's stupid this
movie's pointless this movies dumb I
enjoy the animation but that kind of
makes me hate it even more the same age
you could gone to something so much
better I feel like it's just wasted
everything is wasted except the
opportunity because there is no
opportunity so you can even call it a
wasted opportunity I guess if you have
like a little little kid and they just
want to see Cinderella in a palace try
on dresses spin around all that nonsense
it's fine I mean there's nothing really
ethically wrong form or anything but if
you want show them a fairy tale that's
gonna enchant and delight this shoe is
definitely on
friggin foot
you